[Music]
Skywalker has risen and the nine-part
Skywalker Saga has ended we've misplaced
our Jedi holocrons and our Sith
wayfinder accidentally got flushed down
the space toilet so all we can do is
make some educated guesses about what
the ending of Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker all meant
spoilers incoming
for a movie franchise that's generally
regarded as science fiction there sure
are a lot of Supernatural and probably
ectoplasmic beings hanging around the
Galaxy in Star Wars of course we're used
to seeing Force ghost by now ever since
Obi-Wan told Luke to turn off his dang
iPhone so he could shoot his Torpedoes
into the death star's exhaust Port fans
have accepted the fact that when you're
strong with the force you get to play
Extra Innings as a glowing blue person
and when Yoda himself showed up in the
Last Jedi to mess with Luke and set an
old tree on fire it became clear that
the force ghosts in Star Wars were going
to do a bit more than dispense wisdom
and Exposition
so that's our best guess as to who or
what that crowd of creeps might have
been hanging around with Emperor
Palpatine on exigal at the movie's end
Force ghosts Palpatine made a big deal
about how all of the Sith were fueling
him and it seemed as though the hooded
figures who faded in and out of view
during the scenes with the emperor were
some kinds of spectral Sith Lords
meanwhile Rey's Cosmic pep talk at the
end of the film came courtesy of Jedi
force ghosts and even featured the voice
talents of Jedi actors past and present
including Hayden Christensen and Ewan
McGregor reprising their roles as Anakin
Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi from the
prequel trilogy among many others
one of the most dramatic plot
developments in the film came in the
form of kylo Ren's reversal and
transformation back into his previous
identity of Ben solo his Redemption was
one that was preordained from the first
moment we learned he was Han and Leia's
son in the force awakens not only that
but he's this trilogy's version of Darth
Vader who himself had a rather famous
Redemption of his own at the end of
Return of the Jedi as such the chance
that he would close out the series as a
full villain seemed pretty remote even
still kylo Ren's turn around might have
seemed kind of abrupt so why and how did
he turn to the light
even though he ended each film playing
the part of the villain kylo Ren
expressed conflict and doubts about his
ability to fully commit to the first
order and the dark side in each episode
with each film Ren seemed unable to
fully accept his decision to go bad and
in so doing acted out like an angry baby
slashing consoles with his lightsaber
and smashing his helmet out of
frustration so when Leia expended all
her willpower trying to reach her son
One Last Time apparently going so far as
to pull an Obi-Wan to sacrifice herself
for the good of her kid it may have
opened the door for him to actually see
the light side again from there Rey's
own sacrifice of her Force energy to
heal the fatal wound she dealt him
probably sealed the deal near the very
end of the film Maz Kanata hands
Chewbacca a cute little medal saying
that Leia would have wanted him to have
it the moment kind of comes out of
nowhere but chances are good that folks
in theaters were pretty happy when the
scene unfolded if you're wondering why
the answer can be found 42 years in the
past
back at the end of the first Star Wars
film A New Hope Han and Luke were
awarded medals by Princess Leia in a
ceremony that's full of smiles and great
John Williams music but despite having
just as much to do with her rescue and
the destruction of the Death Star as
anyone Port Chewbacca didn't get Jack
squat Chewie's metal neglect has been a
soar point for Star Wars fans for
decades so it's only fitting that he
finally gets his due in the last movie
additionally the medal was probably the
one Leia had originally given to
Chewbacca's life mate Han which gives
the moment even more significance
so what was this movie actually about
well beyond the obvious answer of wars
in the Stars this is a movie that pins
its emotional core on the idea of
togetherness to lay it out Simply the
rise of Skywalker is about how working
together is good and going it alone is
bad it sounds pretty corny when it's put
that way but the strength of that theme
is undeniable
think about it Rey can't succeed without
help from Ben solo and in the end she
relies on the will of all the past Jedi
to help her defeat Palpatine moreover
Finn and Poe go to Great Lengths to keep
their party together this time around
this is all in stark contrast to the
events of the Last Jedi a movie that
also proves the same theme to be true
though it does so in the exact opposite
way when Finn and Rose break off from
the resistance to help Poe undermine
Admiral holdo disaster follows and
Luke's decision to abandon his sister
and the Republic leaves the Galaxy open
to the rise of the first order
as well as apparently the rise of the
final order and the resurrection of the
emperor
meanwhile Rey and kylo Ren's Connection
in The Last Jedi set up their deeper
Alliance in the rise of Skywalker and
eventually led to the final destruction
of the Empire that connection is fully
realized at the end when she takes on
his family's name of Skywalker and
completely Embraces her adopted family
as her actual one
so with the end of the first order the
final order the emperor and the supreme
leader who's in charge of the Galaxy now
if your answer is the Republic well
you're wrong there too since they got
exploded back in the force awakens it's
an easy detail to forget since we never
really got to see what Leia's newly
established New Republic could do as an
Intergalactic governing body but maybe
it's just as well the answer to the
question of who's in charge is basically
no one the free planets are free and
maybe a new Galactic government will get
together to debate trade routes and
Taxation just like the good old days or
maybe they won't or maybe Rey will
decide to take on the role of empress
after all but she'll be a good one and
she'll rename the Star Destroyer
something nicer like Star deployers
there's no end to the possibilities
the final scene of the film shows Rey
burying the two lightsabers that once
belonged to Luke and Leia at the Lars
family Homestead on Tatooine it's a nice
scene that symbolically plants seeds for
the future of this franchise in an
interesting way even though the
Skywalker Saga has come to an end the
Galaxy is still an awfully big Place
full of people who will find connections
to the force and may end up searching
for answers
that may lead them to Tatooine which
could potentially become a holy site to
Future generations of force users the
future of Star Wars as a film franchise
is a huge question mark though we know
that Kevin feige the architect of the
mega successful Marvel Cinematic
Universe is working on his own ideas for
forthcoming Star Wars movies whether we
ever see Finn po Rey or even Lando or
Chewbacca ever again remains to be seen
But while those lightsabers may be
buried in the sand it stands to reason
that we'll see those legendary weapons
from a galaxy far far away again before
too long
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]